what was the name of the character i
played in the star wars prequels
princess
princess princess i love you i love you
princess
boba tea
hi i'm natalie portman and i am tessa
thompson
and this is do you even know me yeah
that's what it is unilad
what was i voted most likely to in my
high school yearbook
a to be president b to end up in jail c
to be on the quiz show jeopardy or d to
be an olympic medalist
it's a toss-up but um
president
no no no no no that's the third one yeah
yeah
yeah because you know a lot of things
yeah no that's yes that gets that one
right
have you ever had the chance to go on
jeopardy would you ever want to go on a
quiz show i have not and i would
definitely do it if i was asked to
do they have like
they do have like a version with people
who are like known who give their money
to charity and stuff that's you come on
thank you wait this is nasa tell them
people
tell them wait let's get you on there
according to various articles online
what surprising thing have i never done
ridden a bike
watch one of my own movies the whole way
through or eating an egg oh i know this
it's eating an egg yes i know that one i
mean the eating the egg thing is like
the most interesting thing about me no
but my kids are like so
impressed with that they're like they
can't believe it how come
why
it's a good way to teach your kids some
things are just unexplainable some
things just don't make sense there's no
reason there's no particular reason
no
although when i was a kid no one told me
see i didn't have a parent a jeopardy
parent like you no one told me that the
eggs weren't fertilized and they would
never grow up to be chickens it might
have been helpful tonight
okay so
what color are my eyes
they're like hazely
they're
round
but they're so luminous thank you
but they're trying to make up for it and
it's not working
you know what i mean uh-huh thank you
it's like the sun the moon the stars are
in your eyes
lighter than they actually
are
i once said that i wanted to buy a pygmy
goat and name it after which celebrity
gal gadot chris hemsworth or the rock
was it hemsy no
it was gal but it would be called gal to
go
it's so good
what was the name of the character i
played in the star wars prequels
princess
princess princess i love you i love you
[Laughter]
princess
boba tea
finish my twitter bio mostly i talk
about
goats yes
i mean
we've we've already proven that here
haven't we
yes
yes we have why goats in particular
you know
you know the goat thing kind of i've
always loved them as an animal but do
you remember when we were making
annihilation there was a picture of me a
continuity picture that was taken in
between scenes and i'm in the middle of
like we're in some green area in the
countryside in in england and i i was
like i look like a goat and you're like
no you don't and people are like no you
know and then we got a picture
of a goat and it was undeniable it was
like a goat in a green space and put
them side by side and i was like
and then and then i said that and then
someone started a twitter called tessa's
goat suits
for like months it would be one picture
of me
and one picture of a goat that looked
like me all right
what was the name
of the environmentally friendly band i
was part of as a child
a the planet rangers
b solar powered or c world patrol kids
oh man
for your sake i hope it was
solar-powered no
it was world patrol
okay i mean i respect you for not
knowing that
i do have a short clip we can show tessa
today
oh wait
you were legit
[Laughter]
so many more questions
no
do people a lot of people know this
about you like in the public space i'm
not sure
we performed at earth day at the u.n
once that was our biggest gig that's a
big
okay tessa your question how many times
you play class in perry
negative 10 million
okay what was the name of the indie
electro band i used to be a member of
a plant matter
tessa and the thompson oh that's good
or caught a ghost wait what was the last
caught a ghost i think it's caught a
ghost yes although i love
yes or we should start an environmental
friendly band called plant matter which
is not a bad name for a band actually or
clueless
as a young girl i was an understudy in
an off-broadway show alongside witch pop
icon a christina aguilera b britney
spears c lady gaga b britney spears true
all right what was what was she like did
you get the meter i actually didn't work
alongside her i actually took over from
her because she went on to do the mickey
mouse club so i never met her then but i
did meet her later and she was lovely
you went yeah oh yeah wait did britney
spears come to your co didn't we through
a new year's party together together
that's what it was that's so cool you
also look like you're in the oops i did
it again
video in the classroom intentionally
yeah
how many tattoos do i have i have to
admit i just saw your card
i was looking at you and i saw a big
eight on there
in jeopardy not like that oh my gosh
i'm an honest cheater okay i'm gonna
confess
i don't even know if that's true though
did you get more since then
one three i t yeah one two three i have
a tattoo detector it gave me after the
first one no way what is the one he gave
it's three dots
for four or three that's all that maybe
i have eight i don't know yeah
who taught two to three dollars did you
say uh taika like wow that's cool he
gave them to a lot of people
he branded you
[Laughter]
okay well we're out of time but not that
makes you're the winner
not surprising
i made it when you go in jeopardy it's
just questions about me this is a
thompson category exactly
have you stolen any props from the sets
of your movies
yep i have a hammer from just about
every film i think and they're all
scattered around the house in various
places they often end up in the
in the toilet